اذا المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اصدرت مذكره
توقيف بحق بوتين لكن لا يزال بامكانه
زياره العديد من البلدان نظريا يعزل قرار
المحكمه بوتين عن ثلثي العالم لكن مع وجود
193 دوله عضوا في الامم المتحده بمقدور
الرئيس الروسي بوتين زياره 70 دوله على
الاقل غير خاضعه لقرار المحكمه مثل ماذا
الصين اكبر حلفاء روسيا ومن المرجح ان
ترحب بزياره بوتين خاصه وان نظيره الصيني
سيلتقيه في موسكو قريبا ايضا يستطيع بوتين
الذهاب الى ايران وهي حليف رئيسي لروسيا
تؤكد تقارير عده انها زودتها بطائرات بدون
طيار لمجهودها الحربي الهند بدورها ايضا
ليست من الدول الموقعه على قانون المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولن تدن يوما التدخل
الروسي في اوكرانيا بل ان نيودلهي عززت
العلاق ات مع موسكو في تلك الفتره بالحديث
عن حرب اوكرانيا تبقى بيلاروسيا داعمه
روسيا في هذه الحرب مع سماح رئيسها
الاجزاند لوكيشنكو للقوات الروسيه
باستخدام بيلاروسيا كنقطه انطلاقا للحرب
كذلك يحتفظ بوتين بعلاقات قويه مع دول
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق مثل ارمينيا
اذربيجان اضافه للجمهوريه الخمس في اسيا
الوسطى